president Trump is back in Washington
after a surprising end to his trip to
Asia he met kim jeong-hoon at the North
Korean border and became the first
sitting president to cross that frontier
north of North Korean state-run media
called it an amazing event their words
made a US lawmakers question though how
productive that meeting was in efforts
to reach a nuclear deal chip Reid is at
the White House chip what if anything
substantive came out of this meeting
well good morning you know so far there
has been no tangible progress toward any
kind of a new denuclearization deal the
parties are simply heading back to the
negotiating table after talks broke down
earlier this year and meanwhile North
Korea continues to produce material for
nuclear weapons we've agreed that we're
each going to designate a team and the
team will try and work out some details
and again speed is not the object we
want to see if we can do a really
comprehensive good deal moments before
leaving South Korea president Trump said
sanctions against North Korea are still
in place but he left open the
possibility of scaling them back some
point during the negotiations
things can happen earlier in the day
with one footstep the president made
history as the first u.s. president to
enter North Korea the impromptu meeting
unfolded after president Trump tweeted
an invitation to the North Korean leader
the day before CBS News has learned the
president didn't give his staff much of
a heads up about the tweet invitation
but he has been trying to replicate what
South Korean president moon jae-in did
when he met him at the DMZ last year but
the Kim Trump meeting wasn't the only
dramatic moment new White House press
secretary Stephane Grisham was bruised
after getting into a scuffle with North
Korean security guards who appeared to
be blocking American reporters from the
meeting room where President Trump and
Kim spoke privately for nearly an hour
back home Democratic presidential
candidates expressed concern that the
u.s. made no gains this country is no
safer when it comes to North Korea he
keeps having these summits and meetings
that
don't produce anything an initial
meeting between US and North Korean
officials is expected to happen in the
next few weeks president Trump has made
clear he wants Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo to be his lead negotiator but the
North Koreans have previously said they
don't want him anywhere near the
negotiating table meanwhile President
Trump also said he plans to invite Kim
to the White House for a meeting but
there are no details yet
Anthony chip thank you